i'm doing for insane and then game i'm
going to cover so the past couple weeks
i did i really covered like either one
game or a couple games this
time i want to cover there's going to be
some game fragments and stuff but i
really was want to cover
a lot of different opposite bishop
positions
you can do this in like more
systematically but i'm really just
choosing a lot of favorite examples and
showing a lot of key ideas
so one of the things i would say with
opposite bishop end games in general
is that they have their kind of own
rules they're very different from same
colored bishops or rook end games or
pawn end games
so you really have to learn the rules of
opposite colored bishop and games
to learn how they go one of the things
that people do know about them and it's
common knowledge is they tend to be more
drawish in tenancy because
the bishops control opposite squares
basically and
it makes it very very difficult to make
an impasse to break through your
opponent's position
but there's still plenty of occasions
where it's possible and still plenty of
and still plenty of ways you can do it
especially if there are rooks on the
board
uh opposite bishops also are good for
attacking and different things but i
would say that they're actually
a type of end game i really enjoy and i
think they're a lot very misunderstood
because people know them as draws but
there are so many of them where
there's a lot of fascinating things
so this is one where
[Music]
uh this is like a known position which
if you study opposite color bishop end
games and stuff like that this is the
kind of known
situation which i want to show you first
i'm actually going to show you two known
situations first
and they're a bit counter-intuitive
because it's not something you see but
let's say that white has this position
right and
obviously you're trying to draw with the
white pieces
and the question is how do you draw
black's bringing both pawns up the board
and it looks really bad if it was a rook
end game you'd be dead lost if it was
same color bishops almost certainly dead
lost
knight end game you name it king upon
end game of course dead lost
so the question though is how do you
draw this position
with opposite colored bishops so i'll be
monitoring the youtube chat so if you
guys want to say something there
uh hi everyone then feel free but
basically
the question first is how do you go
about drawing this as white
i'm not necessarily looking for a move
i'm looking for a drawing plan right
it's very possible this is quite well
known i'm kind of introducing this
so that i can actually introduce a
problem uh in a couple
a couple positions later and kind of
show you
how this works so exactly bishop g1 and
sit
so this is absolutely correct bishop g1
here
and the whole point is you basically
just sit and wait and the problem black
has is that there's no real way to make
progress
if you play d3 this is something which
you almost always avoid if you're the
attacking side putting this pawns on the
same color as your own bishop
because it allows your opponent's bishop
to just have free reign and you're never
ever going to break through i could just
move my bishop to the end of time
covering the e3 score and you can never
ever make progress
and if there's anything that
if there's anything that shows why
opposite bishops are drawn it's a
position like this
because there's just no way you could
ever control the e3 square and this is
what makes them so drawish that
the bishops cannot control the same
color squares so there's no way to win
the e3 square back and that means that
those pawns are never going anywhere
if you try to play king e5 as you guy
mentioned you just wait
and the whole point is that the king
can't really leave the d4 pawn
because if it tries to go here for
example you just take the pawn and if
you don't
i'm just gonna sit and wait forever and
the whole idea is that i'm waiting for
the move e3 check
and here i do not go back going back by
the way would be simply losing because
now you play king d3
and you're gonna go here and here and
even if the bishop could magically get
over here you're actually going to be
dead lost i'll show you how that works
later
but once the pawns get this far you
can't win but here are the ideas you
play bishop takes c3
king takes and this is a dead draw
so i just wanted to show this position
as part of an introduction
and that's kind of the idea so next i
want to show you a slightly different
position
which is this one
so this position what do you guys think
about it
it happens to be black to move but quite
honestly it doesn't matter
would you say this is drawn still would
you say it's a win for black what do you
guys think
yeah this one black does win so the
question is and we can flip it around to
make it easier for you guys if you'd
like
what is the cur what is the plan for
black
what is black's plan in order to win
so where's the king headed though that's
the key because the whole idea is you
want to get in this move e3
the advantage you have here is that this
bishop on h6 is not nearly as good as on
g1
or on f2 because it does not attack the
d4 pawn
if you were to try to attack the d4 pawn
here i can simply play e3 check
so because the bishop only guards the e3
square it doesn't hit this pawn
it means that black's going to have the
opportunity to improve their king which
they weren't able to do in the previous
example
so if black ever if black plays e3 here
you can simply take the pawn
and now we've reached a drawn position
because you can't mate with the king of
bishop
so e3 checks not what you're looking for
so you want to bring this king
exactly chess king to f3 the question is
how exactly do you go about this
so king f3 is great but how do you get
there
and i would say it's a step-by-step
process to win a position like this
and keep in mind this stuff this doesn't
necessarily work with the pawns far back
because it gives white the opportunity
to set up the great setup with king
after king d2
bishop f2 right where the king and
bishop are in front
so not so easy but how do you actually
maneuver in
so chess king if you ever played the
move d3 we have the same problem we
discussed before right
this bishop controls the square forever
so i could just do this
oops sorry bishops don't move that way
this or this
and there's just no way you can ever
push the pawn to e3
so this d3 move is one you really want
to avoid okay
so this is the key you never want to put
your pawns on the same color as your
bishop like this when you're trying to
push through in a position like this
so i think that uh sun has the correct
idea so
king e5 looks nice but the problem is
that you throw this check and now the
king has to go back
no huge harm done you're still winning
but after bishop h6 you have to start
over again
so the correct solution
is something like king e6 and the idea
is that
no matter what happens let's say the
bishop comes here
king here bishop back king here and
believe it or not white's already in
zugswang
you don't necessarily need zug zwang to
win here but you actually have white in
zugswong
so this is kind of the idea so because
there's no move to stop e3 check
you have to kind of allow it so let's
say they play this move you play e3
check
king e1 king c1 is also possible but
king e1 happens to be more stubborn here
king d d3 so now you're threatening d2
check right and bishop
h a4 and that will win the game
so white has to play here and now you've
reached what you'd call
phase two we've completed phase one
we've gotten the pawns here and here
this we know should be win
the question is what's phase two how do
you win from this position
mj okay
so we've we've already done the first
phase now comes to phase two
so kf3 is one move it's a perfectly good
move but what is our plan that is the
key
and keep in mind there are many many
ways to win this you don't necessarily
have to choose one
king f3 is perfectly good
so let's say we start with this move
and let's say white plays bishop out to
a5
how would you go about it now
because remember you can never play d2
with the bishop covering it unless you
have a king on c2
right bishop a4 is a very good move the
idea is that now you make sure this king
can't move
if you were to try to play king e4 now
there's nothing wrong with it
but what i could do is just wait and
then the second you come here
i can play king here and the idea is
that if you play king b3
now i can play king c1 and you're not
able to get to c2 because my king covers
so the really nice idea is to play
bishop a4 first which is what you
suggest because now the king can't move
so now all i can do is move my bishop
back and forth
the question is how do you finish this
off right
so let's say you go king e4 trying to
come around i go here
let's say you come here because you
don't go to d4 right because i have this
check
remember this trick so you come to d5
and let's say i go here king c4 and here
how would you go about winning from this
position
and this is what requires some finesse
not that much to be fair like you
actually have many ways to go about
winning
bishop c6 is possible but if you play
bishop c6 i'll probably play king d1
and the problem is that now if you play
check i'll go here and now your king
can't get
into c2 very annoying so you'd have to
go around the other way or something
so that one i don't like as much king b3
works
and the idea is that after king d1 what
do you play
so putting the bishop on f3 is nice but
if i then put my king on c1 you still
can't get to c2
so you haven't actually achieved
anything
but yeah king b2 works and then king c2
and this wins pretty easily your neck's
going to go here
personally though my favorite win is the
zugzwang
so in this position my favorite win
is this and what is white's next move
can you guys tell me
what does white do next
pretty cool right there's actually no
move
because if you play bishop b6 then i'll
play check and then i'll queen upon
you can hang your bishop but that's
gonna lose right something like this is
not gonna hold i'll simply take your
bishop
come here and there's no stalemate so i
can safely come here and then
queen my pawn so this is all going to
fail miserably which is good to know
so this just this wins for black for
that reason
so this is one thing to remember that
the bishop here
is far worse than the bishop on these
two squares in order to draw against
these pawns
or pawns similar to it they don't always
draw by the way
right as you can see like it really
matters where the pawns are
but having the bishop in front is
actually better to combat the two past
pawns like this
than if the bishop is behind because you
want to target this d4 pawn
is the key um i would say that if there
were extra pawns on the board this would
be irrelevant because you could just
play e3 so if we have a bunch of other
pawns you're still going to lose
but if we only have these pawns that's
kind of the key
yeah bishop c2 would have worked as well
bishop e3 and bishop's two are the
similar basically
uh but okay so next one
we have this position and believe it or
not this position
is of my own design i actually came up
with
this problem preparing for a student
while i was in the shower i actually
call this the shower problem that's how
it's written into my database
i probably i've almost certainly shown
it before but not for a while
but it's a it's a problem based on these
themes and it has a very partic
kind of peculiar solution to it so
knowing how this works
you can approach this problem in a more
meaningful way right
because the student i gave it to was
quite a strong player but they didn't
know their opposite bishop ending
concepts as well so it became
very very tricky to solve this of course
they did eventually
but the key is now that you know where
the bishop belongs
this problem becomes a lot easier to
solve
so the question is how do you play from
here
after that nice little tidbit i gave you
which was probably more than you needed
to know but i try to give the tidbits
just to make it more interesting
i don't know if it succeeds but so how
does black go about this
so that's a nice line chest king but i
would say that white's not going to let
you play e4 so easily
exactly stopping bishop f2 is important
if you just play something like king d5
and then say bishop g3 e4 bishop f2 you
know it's a draw for what we just went
over
so you can't allow that that's for sure
so i like your move king f3 but the key
is what happens after i play bishop f6
because the problem is you can't allow
e4 e3 that you know is losing
so you must play bishop f6
so i like chess king's move if you go
back to e4 right you're repeating the
position so you have to go to f4
so chess king has the right idea if you
try to play bishop h4 and i play e4
now you can't stop e3 which we know is
winning once e3 gets achieved
as long as you can't sack four right
because here if you try to sack forward
of course
my king defends so you could try and
move like king e1
is kind of interesting um
but this also is going to fail after
king f5
white can go back which is kind of
similar to the other continuation
but if they go to h4 here you have the
same concept right
you can play e4 so the question is how
do you win
after bishop g7 here and this is similar
to the king e1 line if they play bishop
g7
and this is where finding a plan is
crucial not just one move what is
black's plan now
what is the plan
so guys every time you put the pawn on
d3 you're basically giving your opponent
a draw
because now they can play check and
bishop to e3 or something
and this bishop will just move around
till the end of time
and there's no way you could ever try to
win you can play this i just go here
here here and the whole point is that
you can never ever guard this square
enough and you can never dislodge this
king
so this is an example of how drawish the
positions can get so d3 is never ever
going to work
so king f5 is a nice idea but where are
you going after this let's say i just
kind of keep my bishop chilling so if i
ever go here you can play e4 right
and now you know it's a win from what i
just showed you your plan is to do this
and play e3 right
this we know is a win because we just
went over it so let's say i play bishop
h8 i just try to keep my bishop where it
is
very good chess king so king e6 and this
is very crucial if you're going to go
this way
i play bishop f6 bishop h4 and
bishop f2 and then we've in a drawn
position again
so it is extremely important
that you play king e6 and now the whole
idea is that after bishop g7 king d5
bishop f6 for example i play e4
bishop g5 and we're in the same position
i showed you before and your winning
plan is this
so kind of funny right because once you
play here you've actually just
done this except you went doom
and that's the that's the solution so
kind of funny right you actually do like
this whole
circle with your king to try to get it
back to d5
but the whole point of the circle is to
keep white's bishop
from ever getting to f2 because you
control the f6 square from
f5 and e6 so i don't know if that makes
sense but it's kind of
the way that you sort of learn these
positions
so i just wanted to show you a few of
these just they're kind of cool puzzlers
and they're also just good things to
know about opposition
games so now i'm going to actually show
you some practical examples that
occurred in some games and
you guys can kind of try to figure out
what people are doing so the next one
was kind of a beautiful example this was
in the game
leonid stein against tarnowski
and this was a really really nice um
really really nice example leonie stein
was really known for
being an attacker and being very very
good with the two bishops
and he had the two bishops for most of
this game but this ending i thought was
really really instructive
because it looks like white's up a pawn
but it's opposite color bishops right so
oftentimes that means you're not able to
win
but he wins this position in really
beautiful fashion
so first of all we have a choice so i
think it's quite clear what our plan
should be right
what do you guys think
what should our plan be as white
so bishop b7 is just a move but again
when i ask for a plan i'm usually not
asking for just one move right
so i like chess king's plan of d4 to c5
to me there are two major plans right
you can go this way or you can go this
way
and i think it's quite clear one plan is
better than the other which plan do you
like better
hmm
so if you play uh yeah king d4 is
definitely better if you go to f4
the problem is that when i play king d7
king g5 i play bishop king e7 and you
have nothing
the other issue is if you try to play
bishop f6 first the problem is this
bishop tends to block your pieces so
when you go here the king
you're blocked anyway and then if i go
here king here you go here anyway and
the problem is this king can't really
enter
so it's definitely better to go to d4
which is what was played
and black played bishop e8 bishop e8
but what would happen if black were to
play say king b6
bishop d8 is quite strong and the whole
idea is that even if you try to hang on
to the a6 pawn
like you're basically saying all right
if king c5 i take on e4 but the problem
is you don't really have that many moves
so now if i were a white i would take my
time i would just play like something
like g4
let's say you play bishop back to e8 i
just play g5 just keep my pawns nice
and now i infiltrate
now i infiltrate and if even if you try
to save this pawn my king comes over
here and the problem is once i take this
pawn you're kind of hosed right
and this is the reason why white's
completely winning in a lot of these
positions because the h pawn
the pawn on h7 cannot be defended by the
black bishop
it's actually quite funny but you'd
almost rather this pawn be missing so
you could put a bishop on g6
and it's a peculiar pattern in opposite
bishop end games but i would say that
the pawn and h7 is so weak
that you can't really play this way so
in the game he played bishop e8
white played king c5 and then bishop
back to d7
so again phase one kind of complete
what's phase two
how do we further improve our position
yeah i mean i don't know about this zug
swings there yet but it's definitely
coming right but the main problem black
has here is just
there's there's just not enough room and
there are too many weaknesses
you have to keep all these pawns
defended
and keeping in mind that if the king
ever gets here you're just kind of dead
because taking h7 is going to be
extremely strong almost always not if
your king can get here i suppose to f7
but
um but that's just something to keep in
mind
so here white decided to play bishop e7
which is perfectly normal
black plays bishop v8 again nothing too
much is happening
and here what does white do here what do
you guys think
uh you guys are white so you know you're
looking for whites
but again this is the game stain against
taranovsky
so right to play how do you further
improve your position
and one of the things you always want to
ask yourself is is this a position i
have to rush or is this position i can
take my time because they can't improve
and in general when your opponents
playing your bishop their bishop back
and forth or doing
at least very little that's often a
position where you can actually
improve just improve your pieces
yeah so a waiting move is fine but i'm
not really looking to wait i actually
just want to improve so what's the way
white can improve their position
yeah g4 followed by g5 is very nice
so black can play g5 but the problem is
that after something like this
you can simply go here and the problem
is you're threatening this
and you're also gonna threaten this pawn
so if black ever takes on e4
you simply take on b5 and that's gonna
be way too many pawns that you have to
deal with
so even though g5 looks clever it just
doesn't really do much
so black plate here uh bishop g7
bishop d7 rather white plays g5 just
keeping it nice
and now if you ever win that jeep pawn
on h7 it's going to be pretty
pretty rough so here and now white
chooses bishop d6 check
and here there are different options
um so black played king b7
and
if king c8 you can do kind of the same
thing that was done in the game which is
kind of nice and i'll show you that in a
moment
if king d8 you can play bishop b8 king
e7
and then you just bring your bishop
around you play bishop a7
bishop b6 bishop a5
and now your king infiltrates again king
gets to c7
bishop goes here and believe it or not
black azada moves
black actually just loses this bishop
because white simply infiltrated and you
just have no room
and this is the danger when you have
opposite bishops and your pawns bishop
the same color as your pawns and you
don't have a nice outpost
you can actually just run out of moves
sometimes because you're
restricted by your own pawns so this
position would be of course quite bad
so in the game king b7 was played and
then
i want you guys to find how white won
this game the way white won this game
was actually really really nice
i understand that chess bonzo but i
would say that um
you know i can understand that but i
would say that the problem is your
king's never really invading on that
side you're always invading via the
queen side
so because of that you don't have to
worry about putting the pun on g5 so
much
so you guys are mentioning bishop d8
which is indeed the correct move very
guys
and black actually resigned here which i
think was a bit premature but definitely
you can do it
but what happens after king takes b8 so
that's kind of the main idea right the
main idea of this move you're not just
trying to be fancy
if you go this way then i play king c7
and you can't dislodge my king so easily
and i don't know where else you're going
so the this move is not just for show
like there's an actual purpose behind
this move
but bishop b8 so you kind of have to
take this right otherwise i just play
king d6 anyway you're not really helping
yourself
and now what's the plan right the next
move is pretty
pretty simple you play king d6 then i
play king c8
and the key is what is your winning plan
here because here you have an important
decision to make do you take this pawn
or do you ignore it
so we have a king e7 we have a take the
pawn we have all sorts of options
so we have the ignore option but i have
a question what happens after king e7
bishop d7
i assume you're gonna go take my pawn
do you guys see what's gonna happen here
i take on h7 king f7
and here you basically have to force a
draw this is actually really funny this
position is just a dead draw because
after here
you can play h7 but then
there's just stalemate next move unless
i want to commit suicide and move my
king to thee file
so because of this this would actually
be a very very big mistake
and in fact you have to take this e6
pawn
but now you actually win quite easily
because after king here
king f6 there's just no really good way
to stop this now because you're going to
put upon an e6 and that's kind of where
white black will experience problems
so for example if king d7
you can actually play the move king g7
now i wouldn't play e6 check because
then
after king here this king is very active
and it's going to cause problems i think
so i don't know if i would play that
but after king g7 believe it or not you
actually win quite easily
because after king e6 king takes h7
king f7 what is your key idea that's
very very strong here
so you play e6 check very good you can
never move away because king g7 is going
to be too strong
so king f8 and what here
yeah i'm not letting your king escape
right that's a bit
wishful thinking
yeah e7 check probably works but i think
the simplest is just
e5 because the problem is let me see if
you play e7
check i play king f7 you play e5
this probably works no
yeah this should work too i think but
yeah the e5 is very simple
uh as a matter of fact because now
you're just out of moves if king e7 kg7
if bishop moves you can even just take
this pawn and this is simplest
and you're gonna go here and here and
it's just way too much
so kind of a nice line right but believe
it or not after bishop b8 bishop b8 is a
really nice shot
but this is an example of how like very
strong king position can really matter
in these opposite bishop end games and
having the bishop rammed in and only
defending your pawns is really really
bad
quite often because you just run out of
squares and you notice how the pawn on
h7 was really quite weak
so kind of a nice example
this next one is also quite a nice
moment
so this was in the game um zucker
against but fenik um
so but vinick played the movie h5 here
and this is a really really tricky
situation for white because
the pawn the a pawn is quite annoying
your king's kind of tied to it
and it feels like you're gonna get
hemmed in very easily here
so the question is how what is the best
way to defend here
as white
because you have many options you can
move the bishop you can play f4 you can
play h4
and it's a really really complex
position which is not so easy to defend
flip the board that's a good one
flipping the board would be a great
defense for white
but i don't know it's one of those
things where i think a lot of the time
it's easy to look at all the games from
like the winning side
but i think trying to look at it from
the side that's struggling can actually
be
really really valuable
so let's take all the pawn moves first
of all i would say g4 you have to be
very careful with
and the main reason is because you're
going to end up with your pawns on light
squares
so if i were to take everything here
and get this position and play this oops
and play this or bishop e2 for example
this is definitely a draw because now
they're just too few pawns right
but one of the things that i could try
as black would be now to play this move
and this would probably prove a
problematic because i can play king g6
and then at some point just take these
pawns and my pawns are way too far
advanced then your king's way too far
away
so for example let's say you were to
play bishop e3
and just keep the bishop there just for
instance
i could play bishop f1 and even though
you win my pawn
the king is way too far from these guys
right
so what will happen is these pawns will
just advance up the board and you won't
be able to stop them
so this would be an example of what not
to do right
so g4 you have to be very careful of
putting your pawns on the same color as
the bishop it looks weird right
because i said don't put your pawns in
the same color as your bishop
and in a lot of ways that's true but you
also have to keep in mind that opposite
bishops are fluky
and there are times when if your pawns
are going to be weak
you have to be very careful because if
you put them on squares of the same
colors your opponent's bishop
it's good if you're controlling their
bishop it's good if you're pushing them
up the board
if you're on offense if you're on
defense if you have weak
i if you have weak puns you do not want
them on the same color as your
opponent's bishop because they're just
going to get gobbled up
so it's a really fine balance
um i would say that if your pawns are
defensive
meaning that they can be attacked then
you have to be very careful about
putting them on the same color
but if you're trying to be offensive
with your pawns you very rarely want to
put them on the
same color as your own bishop but it's
it's a difficult thing and
it's always changing so there's no like
firm rule
so in any case yeah h4 and f4 h4 was
played in the game f4 is also quite
interesting
but black has a pretty strong resource
here which is h4
and the whole idea is first of all if
bishop f2 you can play this move
and this is quite strong because if pawn
takes pawn
you throw in this move you have to play
bishop g1 to stop h2 and now i take back
and this pawn on h2 is just going to be
way too strong i actually can just waltz
the king
in like this and that's going to be all
she wrote
because you can push your f-pawn but i
can even ignore it if i want
this bishop by the way does a great job
of controlling both these pawns and
controlling the ace
pawn so this would be a disaster
so you have to take it but now i can
take on f4 and i think this position is
a win
because these pawns are actually quite
annoying i play here
say so white's just sitting there's not
much they can do
you play f4 bishop back
and now you bring the king in and white
just kind of runs out of moves right you
play here
eventually you play a2
and the problem is that even though
you've exchanged these pawns
you're winning the bishop and then this
f pawn is just way way way too strong
right you just have no way to combat
this so this is another thing like
double pawns are kind of weird because
they actually if you're in a race like
this they actually
are very very good because you're gonna
win a bishop with your front pawn and
then it's very important
that you have um
it's really really important that you
have
um the second pawn to queen right
sorry so it's it's actually a really
really interesting concept and one of
those things that's easy to
misunderstand
so this is kind of cool in the game h4
was played we'll get to that i think the
best defense is actually bishop b6
and not touching the pawns at all which
is kind of a tricky thing
here one of the ideas by the way is
after king e6 now you can play your g4
move
and the whole point is that now if you
try to go for the same plan
i can play bishop d8 and now i get my
draw because i'm gonna just take these
pawns
gobble gobble right
so remember how before i was saying how
when you're facing the two connected
pawns running up the board you actually
want your bishop in front
when you're trying to attack pawns you
actually usually want your bishop behind
so opposite bishop end games have a lot
of counter-opposing principles
because a lot of the times it's like
okay if you want to defend you put your
bishop in front you're attacking bishop
behind
but it's kind of a difficult concept
because there are so many exceptions to
this
so like most things in chess i always
attach a warning label like okay
yes usually you bought your pawns on the
opposite color of your bishop except
blah blah blah blah blah right
so you don't want to take things as a
firm rule and a lot of it you have to
figure out kind of what people are doing
so i thought king g6 made sense here as
a try
and the idea is you're trying to play
this move f4 and then secure
this weakness on f3 so i think that here
it's very important white play this move
and the idea is that now
you're trying to attack this pawn so
that the pawn can't go to f4
so let's say black goes here you play
bishop back to c1
and the whole idea here is you're
actually trying to force this pawn trade
so if if black plays h4 here i think you
can take and play bishop f4
and the whole point is that it actually
takes a very long time to activate this
king
so for example if you play bishop g2 i
play king b3
bishop takes h3 king c2
and i get this position which is
actually a known draw
and this is again another
um another kind of known motif right
because
you get a position like this right and
the c pawn doesn't even matter
i basically just shuffle my bishop here
and you can't stop ever push your f pawn
if you ever press h3 it can't go
anywhere and if you ever play king h3 i
play king here
and if you go here i go back so we have
kind of a
uh you know like i'm basically like
fencing you off
for some reason there's a name for this
and i'm just completely messing i mean
there's corresponding squares and
different things like this
but basically i'm just trying to create
a fence that you can't cross using my
opposite color bishops
and that's kind of the technique you use
to draw this so this would be kind of
drag if you take on f3 it's also a draw
i think because king takes a2
and you're just reducing the pawns too
much h4 maybe is coming at some point
uh maybe not immediately right but i
think that this is also quite drawish
yeah it's it's pretty unusual right like
you but the key is that you have to
threaten the pawn from behind
and then come back because you can't
allow f4 it's a very very unusual idea
so in the game h4 was played and here i
guess i'll flip it around so you guys
don't have to torture yourselves too
badly
and ask like what can black do to try to
win this position
because the idea that but vinik found in
the game was very very nice
cavablanca was also very very good at
playing these positions
yeah so f4 was played in the game which
is really really nice i was looking at
takes
taking might also actually win i think
because takes
okay if you play f4 then bishop e5 but i
think you can play king e6
and i wasn't actually sure how to draw
this because f4
king d5 bishop f6
king e4 bishop g5
and here you play this move and believe
it or not i think white's in zugzwang
i just didn't see a really good move for
them here which is very strange
um but oh wait no no this is the
position they draw sorry
it's been a little too long yeah here i
think you can draw because you can do
this and then bring your king back
and i think that this position should be
josh because you're basically just
leaving your king in that corner and
just sitting with your bishop
so this would be an example of what not
to do and the same goes for the move g4
because now after f takes g4 if f takes
g4 you're just
too reduced right again i drop the king
back and i put the bishop here and
you're just not going to win
so you have to try this but i can still
play bishop e5
and because i cover the f4 square so
well you don't really have a chance
so the best try is this move f4 once
again
and this position is actually quite
tricky so uh there are lots of
possibilities first of all
if you take this pawn this is just too
much
because i take and now this h pawn
actually just can't be stopped at all
i'm gonna play f4
h4 if you have to play bishop e5 or
something at some point i'll just march
my king up and play
h3 and it's just going to be way way way
too much
so this is just not going to work
uh what else is there there's g
takes f4 is a move
and here it's very important you take
the h pawn if you take the f pawn you
play bishop e5
and you lose the f4 pawn which is very
bad
so you take here
f5 but the technique to win this
position is actually quite funny
so what is the winning plan here and
this is again a really really cool
concept
in opposite bishop endgames that you can
do this is actually a plan which i
played myself
before uh quite a few times where it's
like
it looks like you shouldn't be able to
win but you actually have a way to win
this position
so we can even start with h3 bishop e5
this is fine
and then the question is what is your
current what is your plan to win this
position
so keep in mind a plan right so one move
doesn't really tell me much
so the question is what is your actual
winning plan here
yeah you need your king but how do you
get your king in the game
because that's the challenge so if you
try to play a move like bishop e2
i can play king b3 and now the issue is
that after i take on a3 i start pushing
my c
pawn you're gonna have a lot of counter
play on your hands
and trading pods in general is not what
you want
so i would not really go after the f
pawn because you're allowing black
white to take this a pawn what's really
beautiful here is that this is a type of
position a human can actually understand
that it's probably winning
sooner than a computer can
which is something i really really enjoy
actually
so h2 would be a great idea except that
the problem is that after i take
king f6 king a1 king b1 it's actually a
dead draw
because all i have to do is wait with my
king here and then move my bishop and
then sack for the h-pawn
i've i remember actually robert hess
drew against me using this exact same
tactic
in a game he played really great defense
in a tough end game and he drew this way
this is before he became a gm but he was
already obviously very strong
but um he drew against me using this
kind of trick i remember at a fox was
open
but the basic idea is you leave the king
on a1 and then you just move the bishop
back and forth and you're able to sack
for the
pawn so this is not the way you want to
go about it
so i don't get how the king on g7 is
gonna help king on g2 maybe if you mean
yeah but yeah you have the basic idea
the king has to run up the question is
how it goes about it so there are a lot
of different ways you can actually do
this
but i would say the key is that this
bishop the key thing to realize is that
this bishop
controls all these pawns
none of these pawns can go anywhere
because of the bishop on c4
so you can even defend the a pawn with
that bishop on c4
all you have to do is get your king
across and the bishop will do the rest
of the work
so what i really like is this
continuation bishop d5
and now white has a choice right like
what does white do so white probably
plays a move like king b1 right
because you can't move this bishop if
you try to move the pawn
now my king comes up and my king's gonna
come here and that's gonna be all she
wrote
because you have no good moves so you
don't really have a choice you play a
move like here
and now i think black has a really
really nice move you can actually win in
more than one way i want to point this
out
but there's one way which is quite nice
so let me show you kind of the brute
force way
you can win with bishop takes f3 i think
because king a2
bishop e4 king takes a3 bishop takes f5
and at first this does not look remotely
winning
but i think you have king b2 king e6
temple on the bishop bishop back to b8
for example
king d5 king c1 and this is just in time
because you go here the king gets to g2
i play h2 and i'm gonna win
so this will be the brute force method
this works but i wanted to illustrate
the other one because i thought that
principle wise it actually works fairly
well
to show you and but black has a really
really nice move which i would hope you
which i would like you guys to find
because it's really kind of a cool
concept
so keep in mind if the bishop controls
the whole diagonal
you're probably going to be in good
shape right so it's just a question of
how you go about it
and again it's one of those beautiful
things because computers don't
understand the concept that well they
only kind of calculate the line
so a computer is not going to help you
as much as kind of thinking about it
rules of end game please yeah i don't
think so
um but okay keep in mind that you want
your dark square bishop your dark square
bishop is beautiful it defends
everything you just need a way to get
your king
in so the question is how do you cut off
white's king
that's the key you need to cut off
white's king so that it can't kind of
disturb you because you just need a path
for your king here
bishop b3 very nice and the idea here is
that white basically
has to sit right white plays king a1 or
something i play here
here they can play king c1 it doesn't
really make a difference
and now the question is what do they
play in this position
because here already they have kind of a
problem
so f6 is probably the best try
or at some point f6 right but the beauty
is because they played f6
i now no longer have to go this way
i can now go this way
and now i play king e6
see that so what is so what do they do
now
right they sit like what else can they
possibly do
and then i go here and now they're in
zugzwang because if f4 i can play
h2 and you just lose right f4 h2
if you play f5 i can simply take your
bishop
so this concept is really cool actually
king e6
and the bishop has to move somewhere and
now you can simply take this pawn
and now you can just get in any other
like now you could do the same thing
just move your king around
and there's just no way to stop your
king from getting in anymore
you can also win by brute force as we've
seen but you can just use your king with
because the black bishop
restricts the white king and this is
just a really really cool concept
i actually won a game kind of like this
and i remember my opponent after the
game was basically like you got so lucky
he was kind of not a pleasant person to
be perfectly honest but
i just remember because like the whole
concept was like he thought that this
was an
accident but it's one of those things
where if you're familiar with the
concept of the bishop controlling the
opposing pawns in an opposite bishop end
game with the passer
you can actually use just use your king
well your opponent can't
and being up a king in an endgame is
really really powerful so in the game
uh his opponent played bishop e5 uh
unsugar played bishop b5
and here but vinik found a very very
simple way to win
so first he played the move king e6
bishop c7 if you try taking and i take
this is gonna be a disaster because i'm
going to put my king in f5 and
you're not even going to get anything
you're just going to lose so the bishop
went back
and now he takes and the whole concept
is if you take here and i put my king on
f5
you're going to lose f3 and you're going
to lose pretty easily so for example
here
i'll play a2 just to gain a bit of time
force your king away i play bishop d5
and now bishop e7 for example
i take this pawn you take here i play
king g4 and this king is just i'm gonna
basically queen my f-pawn
and there's nothing you can really do
about it so this would have been pretty
bad
in the game he took here
h3 g4 and the question is how did he go
about winning this position
i don't know if he saw all of this like
it's more that
um like he probably saw some of it and
he saw the concepts and then he used
both to kind of figure things out
because during a game you can't always
figure out everything right
he just called me insane no but like the
thing is like it's not like everything
is planned out
and mapped out and calculated perfectly
every time like very very top gm's and
obviously but finick was a world
champion so he was a very good
calculator
but it's not that they necessarily see
every single line to the end it's more
that they see the concepts
and they know kind of how it goes and
then they do their precise calculation
because they definitely calculate very
precisely right
but yeah the key here is you play h4 if
you play h6 g4 i've showed you this
that after takes takes now it's just a
dead draw because this king can kind of
go back
and i just wait and sack with my bishop
right so this doesn't win so you have to
play with h4
and after bishop h2 he resigned after
bishop e2 because he's just going to
collect everything
and as we've seen the two h pawns are
too much right so even if you get a
position like this
the two h pawns are way too strong right
so i go here
and i win my bishop and there's nothing
you can do about it
so yeah but opposite bishop positions
are really really crazy
and they often look quite drawn like
this one did but as you can see black
has
immeasurable resources to try to win and
overall
it's and again it's a very for me it's
one of my favorite types of end games
because i find that they're very rich
but it could be frustrating to try to
win because there have been times when
i've been up one pawn two pawn three
pawns even
and you just can't win because you can't
control the squares that you need to
control
but as you can see that if you play it
accurately and if you know some concepts
you can actually
win even the most improbable positions
and break down fortresses because that's
kind of what opposite bishops are all
about
anyway i hope you enjoyed that one
i'll be giving a couple more youtube
lectures on my last two
on thursday that will be gm choice and
game of the day or game of the week
rather
and then i'll be doing uh plenty of
twitch streams so if you guys want to
check out the club's twitch
uh definitely do that in any case that's
it for me i will see you guys later have
a good night